it's really it's a really bittersweet
time for us right now and a very
exciting one beyond any finding out that
Janice or nephew the thing that I'm
always thinking about is bran said that
John is heir to the throne but I kind of
imagined Danny feels a little
differently about yeah what's up with
that yeah I know give us a little give
us a little tease about what it was like
tell us what was like reading the
scripts this season and okay so I read
this scripts this season and I in some
kind of a daze walked out of my house
the only thing I check was my keys and
about three hours later I arrived back
home and I still hadn't taken it all in
hey everybody so HBO just did a big TCAs
panel they talked about Season eight
they talked about the prequel series and
they even dropped some information about
Westworld season two so I'll break it
all down but if you're finding me for
the first time be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos starting with the
season 8 stuff so Casey boys was talking
about how they will premiere during 2019
and that sort of shifts their plans for
the prequel series which I'll explain in
a second per any voting rules you have
to air five episodes before May 31st in
order to be considered for the current
year's Emmy nominations HBO is all about
Emmys this also gives you an idea for
when Westworld season 2 episodes are
gonna drop - so talking about Game of
Thrones Season 8 April 2019 the last two
weekends in April are the 21st in the
28th so if they don't start airing Game
of Thrones season 8 by April 28th 2019
they will miss the Emmys cut off for the
most part they've hit that cutoff date
like season 6 I think it was April 24th
so they're like they just slid in right
under that line season 7 obviously we
had that super long delay so that's a
bit of an exception so with all the hype
that they're throwing behind each of
these season 8 episodes being like a
small movie in not an episode of
television I think they're hoping that
they sweep the Emmys like they did a
couple seasons ago
they've already shattered the record for
TV show with a most number of Emmys but
they got shut out at the Critics Choice
Awards so HBO really wants to make a
good season but they also want to win a
ton of awards
so all signs are pointing towards an
April premiere date but then Casey boys
hand-in-hand with that said that because
of that premiere date that they wouldn't
be premiering the prequel series
at least until 2020 he didn't come right
out and say we're definitely premiering
it during 2020 but he said that they
were waiting till the year after season
8 to premiere the prequel series just to
give fans some space just to give that
final season some space because you
basically be shifting towards this other
period in Westeros all these new
characters
it'll give fans like a year just to get
ready for what the prequel series is
going to be but again per those Emmy
voting rules they will probably retake
that traditional Game of Thrones
premiere slot when the prequel series
does drop so just open up a tentative
bookmark for April 2020 for that series
which also means that they'll probably
have to shift the premieres of The
Watchmen TV series that they're
developing and whenever they drop
Westworld season 4 so we'll talk about
that in a second but he did offer up
some more details about the game of
Thrones prequel series he confirmed that
there would be familiar bloodlines which
sort of narrows the time frame because
you have the building of the wall you
have the first men the Andal invasion in
the doom of Valyria so there were a lot
of questions about the really big
historical parents in Westeros that they
might set these prequel series and when
they say that there's going to be a lot
of familiar families it just narrows
that timeframe down quite a bit
because while some of the big houses
like the Lannisters and the Starks go
back to the Age of Heroes before the
first long night the Targaryens go back
to the rise of the freehold both house
Tyrell and house Baratheon didn't become
a thing until after Aegon's conquest
which is thousands of years after the
beginning of House Targaryen and House
start so while it's totally possible
that we could flashback to the doom of
Valyria like once you get up to that
point you're really talking about a
couple hundred years of Westeros II
history and not a couple thousand years
like we thought before so I think it'll
wind up being much closer to events in
present day than we ever thought before
but there's still a number of big
different events that that could be
there's the dance of the Dragons we've
been talking about that quite a bit
there's the first Blackfyre rebellion
they were really like for Blackfyre
rebellions but they're all within a
certain span of time so if you did it
within like 10 years of a show or seven
seasons you could cover most of those
it's always possible if they don't want
to touch a Gon's conquest but they want
to do something before that that they do
the war with the first men when they
invaded against the children of the
force that led to the first long night
they lead up to that event or they could
do the Andal invasion which was quite a
bit after that there are a lot of
invasions like Nymeria with the 10,000
ships is a really big event but it
doesn't feel like it's big enough to
center an entire series around for seven
seasons so again that's why I think it's
probably more likely that they'll do
dance of the Dragons or the first
Blackfyre rebellion because you have all
the familiar families but the events of
it and the characters involved are so
different the Alliance's are so
different so it's about as familiar as
you could get for people who aren't
super hardcore Game of Thrones fans
while at the same time feeling very
different from what we just did on the
main series but again let me know in the
comments what do you actually want them
to do for the prequel series just
remember that they've already confirmed
that they're not going to be doing
Robert's rebellion or the tales of
Duncan egg because George R Martin is
still riding some of those stories in
the big reason for not doing Robert's
rebellion it George R Martin said that
they were already covering most of those
events on the main series so they
weren't in a retread that with a prequel
series but remember there are five
different series they didn't say which
one was their leading candidate right
now he just said that he was really
happy with all of them but the one that
I'm actually expecting to win out is the
one that George R Martin is personally
riding with Bryan cogman who was a
writer in an executive producer on Game
of Thrones for a number of seasons most
of the other people that are developing
the other four ideas are brand new to
Game of Thrones and Bryan cogman was
just sort of like the keeper of the
continuity he was the book guy even
though Dan and Dave are both book guys
before they started the series so of all
the people Bryan cogman
is the most versed in George RR Martin's
canon so any Game of Thrones series that
George our Martin is personally
shepherding probably has a much better
chance of sticking while they were doing
all this HBO Game of Thrones panel stuff
they also confirmed that Westworld
season 2 would premiere in the spring
they didn't say when but again remember
that last April is the Emmy voting
cutoff date so they have to premiere by
April 29th oh they'll miss this year's
Emmys so this sort of confirms that it's
going to be the 22nd or the 29th the
reason why you haven't seen a bigger
trailer yet is because they just wrapped
filming season 2 this past week in
January so what will probably happen is
they'll drop that first trailer sometime
in February you
they attach previews to the premieres of
other series but there aren't that many
really huge HBO series that are
premiering until March and that's a
little bit too late so just stay tuned
for new Westworld season 2 footage but
yes I will be doing Westworld videos
when the series premieres so no worries
there but if you guys didn't know I'm
doing Game of Thrones DVD giveaways all
you have to do to enter just be a
subscriber and leave a game of Thrones
related comments on the video what'll
happen is is we're getting ready for a
trailer season because the Superbowl is
coming and that's typically when people
drop new footage so just look out for
all that stuff but you can click here
for brand new Game of Thrones and you
can click here to watch the Avengers
talking about infinity war and teasing
Hugh Jackman crossover thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight